la ministre de la famille dominique
bertinotti l invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir madame la ministre et merci
d'être avec nous deux dossiers
polémiques vous occupe le mariage gay
bien sûr qui arrive au sénat dans
quelques jours débat jeudi et puis bien
sûr la refonte la révolution des
allocations familiales puisque les
familles aisées toucheront moins pour
aborder ces deux sujets qui appelle on
espère des précisions de votre part
isabelle tournée de l' agence
france-presse
votre partenaire nous rejoindra dans un
instant ce sera ensuite perrine tarneaud
de public sénat
et bien pour parler de vous mieux faire
connaissance et puis une autre autres
partenaires comme chaque semaine et
dailymotion mais d'abord bien sûr madame
bertinotti la sphère cahuzac qui a
rebondi de manière spectaculaire mis en
examen pour blanchiment de fraude
fiscale
votre ancien collègue chargée du budget
a reconnu avoir eu un compte à
l'étranger depuis une vingtaine d'années
votre réaction
écoutez je viens de prendre connaissance
du texte qui est que jérôme cahuzac a
adressé bon j'ai pas envie de faire
d'avoir une réaction là je pense qu'il
faut que la justice fasse son travail et
faut quand même on en penser comment
vous réagissez
des gens peut-être de l'étonnement de la
surprise parce que vous estimez trahi
par son mensonge
je n'aime pas utiliser ces grands mots
je trouve à la fois sa démarche
certainement très sincère dans ce qu'ils
expriment était auparavant il ya une
série de dénégation dans les médias mais
pas seulement vous le savez les yeux
dans les yeux face au chef de l'état et
devant le parlement
c'est une affaire entre lui et lui voilà
et je pense que les conséquences
politiques en ont été tirés lorsqu'il a
présenté sa démission
la justice fait son travail et donnera
l'occasion aussi de s'exprimer devant la
justice mais je n'ai vraiment pas envie
d'aller au delà je pense que oui j'ai lu
cela avec une certaine stupéfaction donc
un avocat un mensonge d'état
vous savez dans ce genre d'affaires moi
je me garde des mots excessifs
il ya une affaire de conscience humaine
voilà je prends acte je sais ce que cela
signifie mais je déteste je n'ai jamais
fait partie de ceux ou de celles qui
contribuent à louer un homme ou au
contraire à l'accabler donc je ne vois
pas pourquoi je changerais de
comportement en la matière alors il ya
un joli cela avec beaucoup de gravité
il ya des interrogations qui fusent à
droite comme à gauche à l'ump comme par
exemple avec jean luc mélenchon qui
s'interrogent d'ailleurs où s'arrête
selon lui où s'arrête le mensonge et à
l'ump certains se demandent si le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ont pu être vos courant
auparavant de ce terrible mensonge
écoutez je n'ai absolument aucune
information et je pense que c'est aux
principaux intéressés de pouvoir
éventuellement s'il le souhaite apporter
à apporter des réponses ou des
commentaires sur ce nouvel nouvel
épisode est ce que vous redoutez comme
françois bayrou par exemple des effets
dévastateurs pour l'ensemble du monde
politique mais je pense qu'il n'est
jamais bon
quel quelles que soient les rangs
politiques car voilà les affaires ne
sont jamais à mettre à l'honneur
de la démocratie nous savons combien la
confiance des français à l'égard des
politiques est quelque chose de très
précaires et de fragile évidemment ce
genre d'affaires ne va pas dans le sens
d'un renforcement de la confiance de nos
concitoyens mais je n'irai pas non plus
dans la stigmatisation de tout le monde
politique
il ya énormément d'élus qui font leur
travail de façon exemplaire
donc comme je n'irai pas dans la
stigmatisation des médecins ou de
n'importe quelle catégorie profession
accord alors françois hollande avait
pris une décision assez rapide
avant même la mise en examen qui vient
d'intervenir seulement de monsieur
cahuzac est ce que aujourd'hui on doit
aller plus loin et par exemple ce n'est
plus la responsabilité du chef de l'état
mais de son parti est ce qu'il ne doit
être exclue sur lequel usa n'est pas du
parti socialiste écoutez je pense que
c'est une question oui c'est une
question alors qu'il est question
je ne sais pas je pense que là pour le
coup la faire et d'une autre d'une autre
dimension et je ne crois pas que ce soit
la priorité des priorités de savoir si
jérôme cahuzac doit être mais si je vous
pose la question parti je cite il serait
légitime je n'ai plus dans son
portefeuille la carte à fait légitimes à
me poser cette question mais je suis
tout à fait légitimes à trouver que
cette question en tout cas ce soir n'a
pas lieu d'être que c'est pas la
priorité des priorités
je pose encore une question sur le sujet
cet embarrassant mais
imaginez jérôme cahuzac revenir sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale comme
ancien ministre enfin écoutez nous n'en
sommes pas là il faut que la justice
d'abord parce qu'elle se prononce et il
sera toujours temps de voir en fonction
de ce que sera le verdict de la justice
de voir ensuite ce que peut-être
l'avenir de jérôme cahuzac enfin est ce
que l'on redoutait un effet délétère sur
le gouvernement de cette affaire cahuzac
et ses développements
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas que ce soit
un effet délétère je ne pense pas je le
dis très très clairement nous avons eu
peut-être
voilà un premier moment qui a été au
moment de la démission de jérôme cahuzac
je pense que cette démission d'une
certaine façon tourner une page pour le
gouvernement et que nous sommes nous en
tant que membre du gouvernement dans une
autre page voilà c'est quelque chose
maintenant qui appartient à jérôme
cahuzac avec des rebondissements mais je
ne crois pas que cela ait d'incidence
sur le gouffre alors le gouvernement
reste ce coup et bien sûr les attaques
sont très très forts pour un journal le
figaro ce matin après un remaniement
pour donner un nouveau souffle à
l'équipe parce que vous en manquez
écoutez d'abord moi je voudrais dire que
il n'est pas un jour où le figaro ne
stigmatise l'action du gouvernement nous
nous sommes dans l'action ils sont dans
leur rôle légitime d'opposants et je le
comprends tout à fait maintenant il
pourrait être dans un rôle d'opposant
plus constructeur ou constructive et je
trouve que la façon dont il se comporte
depuis le début je le vois moi je
n'étais pas parlementaire auparavant
donc je découvre ce que sont par exemple
les questions d'actualité le mardi et le
mercredi et je trouve une droite très
qui a du mal à accepter le verdict des
urnes qui a du mal à trouver légitime
que la gauche soit au pouvoir et elle
est au pouvoir pour cinq ans elle est au
pouvoir pour cinq ans les députés ont
été ont été élus pour cinq ans henri
guaino mais bien bien sûr que bien sûr
que non je trouve très fort je tiens à
le dire qu'on puisse parler de crise de
régime
venant de rang qui n'ont cessé pendant
les cinq années précédentes de diviser
la société française de pointer tel
groupe contre tel groupe vous savez vous
souvenez y avait ceux qui se lever tôt
contre ceux qui se lever tard il y avait
les chômeurs contre les actifs qu'il y
avait des assistés contre lennon assisté
à certains enfants se reproche
aujourd'hui on en parlait dans un
instant je pense que véritablement ce
qui a changé pour le coup et ce sur quoi
tout le monde peut se mettre d'accord
c'est que nous avons rétabli les
conditions d'un véritable dialogue
dialogue avec les syndicats dialogue
avec les associations dialogue avec les
citoyens c'est à dire qu'un moment donné
on peut avoir le regard que l'on veut
sur les réformes et la politique est
décidée
mais au moins nous sommes dans cette
démarche d'associer l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens quelles que soient leurs
responsabilités à l'élaboration et à la
co construction de cette politique
j'en parlais de dieu d'un remaniement
éventuelles on sait que votre amie
ségolène royal frappe à la porte vous
pensez qu'elle aurait sa place à quel
manque au gouvernement aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est pas des affaires de
personne je pense qu'à m'en donner un
remaniement est une chose suffisamment
importante et sérieuse pour que c'est un
sens politique et donc voilà ça
appartient au président de la république
s'il estime qu' il n'y a pas cette
nécessité est le jour où il décidera
qu'il y à une nécessité cela lui
appartient
c'est pas sous les
les vociférations de certains à droite
que on entend certains qui voudraient la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
dont qui voudraient un remaniement c'est
beaucoup d'agitation
moi je préférais entendre des idées très
constructive
nous avons besoin de sortir de la crise
nous avons besoin de l'effort de tous et
le redressement se fera avec tous alors
vous l'avez rappelé les récents vous
avez découvert l'assemblée nationale
notamment la séance des questions
d'actualité comme ministre auparavant
vous étiez maire du 4e arrondissement de
la capitale
au nom des municipales est ce que vous
êtes inquiète pour la succession de
bertrand delanoë
non je ne suis pas du tout inquiète
d'abord parce que je sais que anne
hidalgo sont rapportés ou si le bilan de
deux mandatures de bertrand delanoë que
des éléments comme la moralisation de la
vie politique parisienne comme le
développement des logements sociaux le
développement des places en crèches
seront à mettre au crédit de cette
municipalité qu'il y a encore des
perspectives d'avenir pour cette ville
et qu'elle saura les portes et
l'écologiste jean vincent placé lui se
dit extrêmement inquiet estime que la
campagne d'anne hidalgo manque de
dynamique
nous sommes à un an des élections
municipales
municipales donc je 50 50 maximum
j'attends de voir je crois que ce sera
projet contre projet jallet est ce que
vous avez entendu une proposition de
nathalie kosciusko morizet moi je n'en
ai pas entendu mais son profil on peut
déjà le juger et on est qu'elle a le bon
profil sociologique un peu bonbon
compatibles vous savez moi je respecte
vraiment une langue en diversité la
diversité de l'électorat parisien
il n'est pas que comme on vous dit bobo
écologie
faty bhl je veux dire il ya aussi des
hommes et des femmes qui appartiennent à
toutes classes sociales à paris et qui
voteront alors pour revenir d'un mot sur
la série sachez que les mots employés
par françois hollande sont ceux ci
dénoncent une faute morale
impardonnable c'est un petit peu ce que
l'on nous disait avec une certaine
jeunes débutent cette émission
évidemment beau on ne peut pas si c'est
un homme on ne peut pas se satisfaire de
france l'un désarroi après sa faute à
son mensonge merci on va maintenant
aborder en détail les deux sujets de
votre ministère qui font polémique je
disais tout à l'heure le mariage est
donc et puis les allocations familiales
avec isabelle tournée de l' agence
france-presse
mais on va d'abord voir comment
s'annonce le débat au sénat sur le
mariage pour tous ce sera donc jeudi -
d'invectivés apparemment mais les
opposants moins d'amendements ou six
mois d'amendements mais mais mais mais
attention vous allez devoir les
opposants ne désarment pas ma tin de
bélanger un peu moins de 200 amendements
déposés par l'ump au sénat on est bien
loin des quelques 5000 débattu en
janvier à l'assemblée nationale cette
fois pas de doublon artificiels ni de
proposition farfelue
l'ump veut un débat serein nous voulons
apparaître comme particulièrement
sérieux et étayée dans nos discussions
et donc démontré qu'en réalité le
travail était insuffisamment préparés et
que de trop nombreux points restent dans
l'ombre notamment ce qui concerne
l'adoption mais c'est un débat qui sera
valorisée au sénat parce que il faut
penser à ça aussi je pense que les les
insultes les oreilles et aurions tout ça
ça ne grandit pas l'image des
formée des deux côtés chacun fait ses
comptes au sénat la majorité dispose de
six voix d'avancé sur l'opposition
mais à droite comme à gauche des voix
dissidentes se font entendre
quatre sénateurs ump ont annoncé qu'ils
voteront pour d'autres comme roger
karoutchi ont prévu de s'abstenir à lui
dénient chantal jouanno fait également
partie des partisans du texte
on n'est pas nombreux à droite à être
clairement pour le texte beaucoup vont
s'abstenir
beaucoup y compris de mes collègues vont
s'abstenir parce qu'ils sont comme je
vous le disais pour le mariage mais pas
pour l'adoption plénière enfin pas pour
le futur texte pma gpa
donc ils vont s'abstenir donc mais
plutôt minoritaire mais je pense
vraiment qu'il passera j'ai pas
tellement de doutes sur le sujet à
gauche l'interrogation porte surtout sur
les sénateurs de l'outre-mer plusieurs
d'entre eux pourraient s'abstenir voire
voter contre car leurs électeurs sont en
majorité hostiles au projet même si les
pro mariage sont confiants le vote
s'annonce plus serré qu'à l'assemblée il
ya toujours en suspens sur un texte
comme ça et le suspense parce que sur
les textes de dison de société entre
guillemets au dernier moment tel ou tel
sénateur d'un côté comme de l'autre de
l'hémicycle peut dire ah mais non moins
en confiance je suis pour même en
conscience je suis contre je ne peux pas
vous suivre etc
comme on l'avait vu un peu pour la peine
de mort pour l'avortement par exemple le
débat s'ouvre jeudi et devrait durer une
dizaine de jours au maximum puis le
texte reviendra à l'assemblée pour une
deuxième lecture
l'opposition elle a déjà prévu la suite
elle saisira le conseil constitutionnel
voilà donc avec nous alors le texte
arrive jeudi au sénat et ses opposants
espèrent qu'il sera mise en échec est ce
que vous craignez un tel coup de théâtre
rejet du texte
écoutez très honnêtement non je pense
qu'il y aura un débat parce que il ya
des opposants à ce texte mais voilà nous
avons été auditionnés par les sénateurs
voilà christiane taubira et moi même et
j'ai senti quand même un esprit de
dialogue et je reste confiante sur le
vote des sénateurs et sénatrices je ne
sais pas mais vous avez entendu et il va
y avoir à sur les rangs de la droite des
sénateurs qui aiment ou sénatrice qui
vont soit voter pour soit s'abstenir et
c'est assez cohérent je veux dire dans
toutes les réformes sociétales
vous avez toujours eu des dépassement
des clivages politiques traditionnels
c'était le cas les vg a été voté grâce
aux voix de gauche
bon bah là effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques défections à gauche qui seront
peu nombreux je pense mais il y aura
aussi des votes favorables à droite qui
vous sont indispensables
cela dit permettront d'avoir une
majorité au sénat
certains juristes ont pointé des risques
d'inconstitutionnalité du texte le
groupe ump au sénat entend d'ailleurs
opposer des arguments temps d'opposer
des arguments constitutionnels notamment
sur la question de l'adoption plénière
pour les couples homosexuels
elle c'est un risque que vous prenez au
sérieux il faut toujours prendre les
choses au sérieux la même façon vous
parliez tout à l'heure des municipales
parisiennes faut jamais sous-estimer les
adversaires et les respecte et je pense
que c'est la meilleure des choses est la
meilleure façon de gagner les victoires
donc effectivement il faut regarder les
arguments je pense que voilà au
ministère de la justice les choses ont
été suffisamment approfondie est étudié
pour que les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité soit vraiment
minime
je ne préjuge pas de ce que sera
l'analyse du conseil constitutionnel
bien bien évidemment mais j'ai envie de
dire vous savez même ce débat sur
l'adoption plénière
on sent bien que dans les opposants aux
mariages
on sent bien que les digues recul on
était contre le mariage et puis après
ils sont contre et sont toujours il
considère en tous les cas que se
contentait d'une adoption simple pour
pour les enfants pour leur donner un
cadre juridique dans ces familles
homoparentales ce serait déjà une façon
et bien d'apaiser les choses vous ne
voulez pas les entendre sur ce point
précis ou non parce que c'est une loi
d'égalité
c'est une loi d'égalité c'est à dire que
ces mêmes droits mêmes devoirs
au nom de quoi pourrait-on dire parce
que les uns sont homosexuels et les
autres pas vous n'aurez pas les mêmes
droits au nom de la filiation façon la
filiation naturelle si vous prenez le
cas de couples hétérosexuels qui
adoptent la filiation biologique est née
d'enseignés pardon dans certains cas ce
qui est le cas d'adoption plénière alors
la mobilisation des anti ont l'âge ea ne
faiblit pas depuis six mois elle va même
en s'amplifiant peut même s'amplifie
auront su parler de radicalisation pour
certains radicalisation oui
amplification je ne parie leur chef de
file frigide barjot aller jeudi dernier
jusqu'à évoquer un risque de guerre
civile
ils ont en fait le sentiment de ne pas
être entendus pourquoi est ce que le
président de la république n'accepte
utile pas de les recevoir de nouveau à
l'elysée est évident à savoir vous même
dominique bertinotti vous attendiez-vous
très honnêtement à une telle
mobilisation
avant j'allais commencer par le dernier
né des choix sûrs oui moi je m'attendais
je ne connais pas de débat de société
qu'il n'ait pas provoqué justement de
véritables passions et donc je dirais
d'une certaine façon des clivages qui
fasse que effectivement surtout les
débats de société
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de débat
consensuel
donc il y a deux visions qui qui j'aime
pas le terme d'affrontements mais qui
sont l'une face à l'autre
et effectivement mais maintenant quand
on dit on ne les reçoit pas enfin quelle
plaisanterie
ils ont été reçus et au fond d'une foule
en par françois hollande
mais ils ont été reçus et entendus par
que s'établira et par moi-même
ils ont été reçus et entendus au moment
des auditions par l'assemblée nationale
des auditions par le sénat donc ce que
je constate aujourd'hui c'est que pour
eux être entendu c'est renoncer au texte
et renoncer au texte
ça serait de dire écoutez il n'y a qu'un
seul modèle de familles possible en
france le modèle classique sauf que la
société à l acte est depuis fort
longtemps qu'il y à une diversité des
modèles familiaux
est-ce que vous utilisez si vous me
permettez en introduction le terme de
révolution et pour les oeufs sont
familiers avec lui mais je vais vous
dire la révolution si révolution il ya
c'est la révolution silencieuse des
familles depuis les années 70 les
modèles familiaux se sont diversifiées
il ya des familles homoparentales il ya
des familles recomposées il ya des
familles monoparentales
il ya des familles classiques que
fait-on il faut absolument au fond
aujourd'hui ce que nous demandent nos
concitoyens c'est une véritable
protection juridique donc modernisons le
droit au regard de ce qu'est devenue la
leur site et vous avez défendu il ya un
instant la filiation l'adoption plénière
on est des couples familles
homoparentales mais alors au nom de
l'égalité que vous venez de rattraper
pourquoi ne pas donner de la procréation
médicalement assistée aux couples de
lesbiennes à l'heure parce que le
président était on ne peut plus
noir la première loi correspond à
l'engagement 31 qui prévoyait si vous
relisez dans les 60 engagement des gens
dans 31 lorsqu'il était candidat il a
envoyé des courriers aux associations
homosexuelles
sauf que l'engagement 31 c'est le
mariage et l'adoption ouvert aux couples
de même sexe
il a été dit très clairement que la pma
seraient renvoyés ultérieurement
comme nombre de pays ont fait je tiens à
dire qu'il ya des pays qui ont fait une
sorte de global puis à des pays qui ont
procédé par étapes
il ya eu un chiffre de le faire elle va
forcément est ce que est ce que vous
cela sera abordée vous même est ce que
vous considérez que ce serait un progrès
pour la société que d'ouvrir la pma aux
couples homosexuels
et est ce que vous allez pousser pour
que ce soit inclus dans la future loi
sur la famille les sur cette question de
la pma je pense que très intéressant
font au travers de votre question vous
pointez une chose qui moi m'a un peu
surprise quand je suis rentré dans le
dans le débat à l'assemblée nationale
c'est que au travers de la de
l'ouverture du mariage et de l'adoption
aux couples de même sexe c'est toutes
les questions de famille qui ont été
abordés indépendamment de la question de
l'homosexualité comme si au fond pendant
des années des années on n'avait pas
voulu voir l'émergence d'un certain
nombre de phénomènes familiaux et la
question de la pma elle l'est elle fait
partie de ce même corpus la pma elle
existe déjà en france elle existe déjà
en cours est coupé pour les couples
hétérosexuels
tout comme l étranger pour les combles
et voilà et elles existent à l'étranger
et pas très loin puisque c'est en
belgique ou en espagne donc à deux
heures de paris
vous pouvez avoir recours à une pma
lorsque vous êtes couples de femmes
homosexuelles
donc voilà c'est toutes ces
interrogations qu'il faudra prendre en
compte est ce qu'on regarde lucidement
ce qui existe déjà aujourd'hui
ou bien est ce que on se met je dirais
un écran noir devant les yeux pour ne
pas voir ça mérite d'être discuté et il
y aura ce débat
parler des allocation isabelle un mot
encore sur un freinage risque pour vous
c'est la pire des homophobes comme le
dit jean-pierre michel qui va pourtant
ps du texte je vous disais je n'aime pas
les mains les mots excessifs donc
simplement il est un argument qui qui
quelque part me choque profondément
c'est lorsqu'on dit mais enfin l'égalité
c'est ça ne veut pas dire gommer les
différences quand je dis aux partisans
de frigide barjot
enfin les hommes et les femmes sont pour
que je sache différents est ce pour cela
que les hommes et les femmes n'ont pas
droit aux mêmes droits justement on me
dira mais c'est pas la même chose bien
sûr que si c'est la même chose
est-ce que la sexualité doit être un
critère discriminant au regard du droit
nous nous répondons que non que c'est
une loi d'égalité est ce qu'elle était à
sa place cette frigide barjot ce
week-end au congrès de l'union des
organisations islamiques de france au
bourget l'a déclaré notamment à propos
des femmes voilées de leur choix là
aussi grande sur ce sujet alors je sais
pas si c'était sa place et j'ai envie de
dire les actes et la démarche de frigide
barjot
je lui laisse mais sur la question du
voile il ya deux choses différentes qui
a porté un voile parce qu'on a des
convictions religieuses
c'est une chose sur laquelle personne
entend remettre en cause cette liberté
il ya en même temps lorsque vous assumer
une mission de service public et au x 9
c'est le flou de la loi actuelle c'est
de reconnaître que lorsque vous confiez
vos enfants dans une crèche collective
vous êtes dans une mission de service
public si c'est une mission de service
public
alors là ils s'étaient et notre
indépendance et pour un consensus à des
chefs d'état les allocations familiales
potentiellement explosif les allocations
familiales alors le gouvernement
attendait le rapport fragonard pour
prendre des décisions
ce rapport il a été dévoilé aujourd'hui
dans la presse et il prévoit une
modulation notamment des allocations
c'est à dire qui est plus riche touchent
ou toucheront moins c'est précisément ce
qu'a dit françois hollande jeudi dernier
il a aussi dit qu on toucherait pas aux
principes d'universalité des allocations
mais il avait promis
que voilà qu'on ne peut que les
allocations resteraient les mêmes pour
tout le monde alors est ce que c'est un
tabou est tombé ou d'abord si vous
regardez les multiples sondages qui sont
sortis sur cette question les français
sont plutôt favorables justement à cette
modulation est pourquoi au fond il
faudrait s'interroger pourquoi les
français ont aussi évolué sur cette
question là ils ont évolué tout
simplement parce que là aussi la
situation des familles a beaucoup changé
vous avez une famille sur cinq qui est
une famille monoparentale et dans ces
familles monoparentales c'est à dire à
peu près de 8 millions de personnes
vous en avez 30 % qui vivent en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté ça veut dire qu'ils
vivent avec moins de 950 euros par mois
est donc tirons prise de fonction en
famille pour les femmes et surtout oui
mais on prévoit aussi pour que cesser de
faire des économies mais en même temps
le premier ministre s'est engagé au
renforcement de certaines prestations et
donc l'idée pourquoi il faut à la fois
réfléchir sur cette architecture globale
des allocations c'est que la branche
famille est déficitaire 2,6 milliards je
tiens à dire que en 2007 elle ne l'était
pas et que le déficit n'a cessé de se
creuser cette saison exceptionnelle et
certains experts et d'autres disent que
s'il faut en chemin mais y est en
déficit c'est ce qu'on a puisé dedans
pour alimenter la branche vieillesse
alors c'est pas la faute de la branche
famille mais alors qu'est ce que l'on
fait qu'est ce que l'on fait on diminue
encore les retraites on considère que le
vieillissement est une chose que l'on ne
doit pas accompagner et qu' on ne doit
pas être solidaires entre générations
moi je pense qu'il est beaucoup plus
raisonnable de regarder effectivement
quelles sont les catégories qui ont le
plus besoin de ces allocations
familiales parce que au fond le coup je
n'aime pas beaucoup utilisé ce terme est
là mais le coût de l'éducation d'un
enfant est vraiment le même dans des
familles très modestes dans des familles
de classe moyenne que dans des familles
ese simplement le niveau des revenus
n'assure pas le même type d'éducation
alors nous savons bien que les
arbitrages ne sont pas encore rendus
sept dont les prochains jours mais je
leur ai quand même savoir vous même
madame bertinotti
à partir de quel seuil de revenus vous
considérer qu'un ménage pourrait se
passer d'une partie des allocations
familiales
je suis solidaire d'un gouvernement je
suis solidaire des arbitrages qui seront
rendus par le président de la république
et le premier ministre
donc mon avis personnel n'ont en
l'occurence pas d'importance c'est au
regard effectivement de la façon dont on
peut combler ce déficit de respecter de
pouvoir réorienter une politique mieux
ciblées vers les plus modestes est de
savoir aussi tenir compte que les
classes moyennes doivent aussi pouvoir
bénéficier de ces allocations familiales
donc aujourd'hui rien n'est arbitré sur
en clair ou où sera placé le curseur
vous avez vu puisque dans la presse
les schémas sont explicités et bien on
nous ne sommes pas encore autant de
l'arbitrage qui viendra très rapidement
qui viendra très rapidement mêlé c'est
déjà le président du haut conseil à la
famille remettre officiellement premier
ministre son rapport
qu'est ce qu'il n'a pas fait pourquoi ne
pas aller encore plus loin et ne pas
être plus radical finalement pourquoi
tenir le temps à ce principe
d'universalité
parce que si une famille se retrouve par
exemple avec 40 euros d'allocations par
mois tout en gagnant six sept ou huit
mille euros on peut estimer que ça ne
changerait pas beaucoup les choses pour
elle alors et je te croire ma venir à
tout prix finalement ce que je dise que
c'est tout c'est une façon de dire que
la république reconnaît tous ses enfants
voilà c'est pas ce que disent les
associations familiales mais et 10 ans
touchant
la question clé de l'universalité et
bien on revient sur une saison lorsque
l'un des comédiens
je sais pas ce que ça aura des
conséquences peut-être sur la natalité
vous savez si on ne réforme pas je le
dis très clairement si on ne réforme pas
et qu'on ne me dernis pas notre modèle
social
le risque c'est qu'il n'ya plus de
modèle social parce que'il à la société
a évolué on sursaute et sociales tron et
que piéton ou troué c'est à dire alors
mettant en cause l'universalité
c'est pas l'universalité c'est là les
associations ont commencé la même somme
quel que soit le niveau de revenu
moi je dis simplement j'entends bien le
les associations familiales je leur dis
simplement regarder écouter
attentivement nos concitoyens nos
concitoyens y compris dans les classes
les plus aisées sont prêts à entendre
effectivement qu'ils perçoivent moins en
termes d'allocations familiales non nous
nous estimons qu'il faut que la
république continue à reconnaître
effectivement tous ces enfants et c'est
une façon de dire bien on reconnaît tous
nos enfants
peut-être mais ça aussi la symbolique a
aussi son importance alors il va sans
doute falloir aller plus loin que la
salle diminution des allocations pour
les familles aisées si on veut rétablir
les équilibres de la branche famille
socialiste
d'autres pistes ont été ont été évoquées
notamment le
le quotient familial alors faut-il
encore baissé le plafond du quotient
familial
va-t-il falloir s'attaquer à d'autres
prestations par exemple comme la garde
d'enfant alors déjà sur la question de
la garde d'enfant n'est pas évoquée dans
la est évoquée par par des députés
socialistes en mai je pense que les
arbitrages seront faits à partir des
conclusions de l'ensemble du rapport
fragonard et je voudrais dire aussi une
chose lorsque j'entends évidemment des
oppositions se manifester et moi j'ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention ou
xavier bertrand je crois même c'était
ici à public sénat dire dire que ça ne
lui paraissait pas absurde que les
supprimer carrément les allocations
familiales
il n'a même plus radicale j'ai entendu
raymond soubie ancien conseiller social
de nicolas sarkozy tenir à peu près le
même discours j'ai entendu alain juppé
donc vous voyez bien que cette question
elle est commune
oui j'ai entendu oui mais je pense qu'à
un moment donné aussi il faut savoir
vers quel type de politique juste
sachant que nous sommes dans un contexte
où nous avons à réduire les déficits et
que de ne pas réduire les déficits c'est
hypothéquer véritablement notre avenir
et pour le coup hypothéquer nos guides
associations familiales alors c'est une
c'est une piste écoutez je ne je pense
que c'est un ensemble sur lequel le
gouvernement aura à se prononcer voilà
donc il ya des pistes différentes qui
sont évoqués par bertrand fragonard
nous nous sommes en train de les
examiner et je vous le dis les décisions
seront prise assez rapidement alors
j'avais lequel est spécialiste en plus
tôt quand même que c'est un tabou qui va
tomber avec cette réforme des
allocations familiales madame la
ministre or on s'en souvient d'autres
ministres s'y était essayé
bahia j'ai payé jospin également ils se
sont tous cassé les dents pourquoi ça
passerait mieux avec jean marc ayrault
non parce que je crois qu'il ya une
évolution des mentalités qui s'est faite
je suis sûr que c'est la solution
éthique du premier ministre n'est pas
très bonne dans l'union par les sondages
parlons des sondages oui les sondages la
popularité ne peuvent d'accord forcément
mais en même temps quand vous regardez
par exemple les sondages sur on parlait
du mariage les gens ils sont favorables
quand on parle d'une mise sous condition
de ressources des allocations familiales
ils disent y sont favorables je pense
que c'est bien aussi qu'il y ait des
évolutions dans le temps les gens sont
tout à fait conscients qu'il y à la
crise et qu abandonner aussi ce qui fait
la force de notre modèle c'est bien la
solidarité c'est bien abandonné essayer
de faire en sorte que même dans les
difficultés même dans les épreuves
personne ne soit laissé sur les bords du
cheveu question juste peut-être pour
résumer que ce soit sur le mariage ou la
réforme des allocations voit bien que ce
sont quand même des sujets qui génère
des tensions des crispations
est ce que le climat peut-être un petit
peu moins peut-être un petit peu moins
les oppositions
est ce que dans le climat social actuel
ces réformes sont vraiment opportune je
vais vous répondre de façon différente
pour les deux les deux réformes
les allocations c'est vraiment nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à ne pas lutter
contre les déficits
et je le répète ne pas lutter contre les
déficits hypothéquer notre avenir donc
c'est totalement portant sur le mariage
il n'ya pas incompatibilité entre
réformes sociétales réformes sociales je
le dis même si ça agace certains en 1944
en pleine reconstruction au moment de la
libération pleine reconstruction de
gaulle a fait donner le droit de vote
aux femmes c'est vrai qu'on dit quand
même d'en faire le minimum avec un peu
trop prochaine loi sur la famille la
femme mais pas du tout parce que ça
concernera l'ensemble des familles et
pour le coup parler du statut du beau
parent parler de leurs effets
de l'adoption par les de médiation
familiale ça fait mal et isabelle merci
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui on va
parler maintenant de vous un madame la
ministre avec perrine tarneaud on vous
connaît peu en effet marie brémaud
dresse votre portrait dominique
bertinotti est une femme fidèle un homme
tout d'abord son mentor françois
mitterrand il la repère et la charge en
1992 du suivi des archives
présidentielles et de la création d'une
fondation qui deviendra à l'institut
françois mitterrand fidèles ensuite à
une femme ségolène royal soutien de la
première heure en 2006 dominique
bertinotti était encore aux côtés de la
présidente de région durant les
primaires socialistes de 2011
puisqu'elle était sa directrice de
campagne et en même temps avec beaucoup
de courage de rester aux côtés de
ségolène royal ce que nous on a été
quelques uns à faire jusque la dernière
primaire socialiste dans la mesure où
sincèrement il y avait plus de coups à
prendre que davantage à gagner donc elle
a montré qu'elle était capable de se
placer dans des situations difficiles tu
ne garantissait pas le succès
les mauvaises langues disent qu'elle ne
doit son entrée au gouvernement qu'à sa
proximité avec ségolène royal
mais les habitants du 4e arrondissement
de paris savent que celle qui fut leur
mère pendant plus de dix ans est une
bosseuse tenace est convaincu
visiblement ceux qui la côtoient ne
reste pas longtemps insensible à cette
socialiste engagée c'est le cas de son
ami éditeur jean ferreux quel regard je
porte sur la fin alors je vais vous
faire une réponse de macho je la trouve
très séduisante elle n'est pas
manipulatrice elle est séduisante dans
la mesure où il émane d'elle une
séduction naturelle séductrice mais
attention quand historienne de formation
a une idée en tête
difficile de la faire changer d'avis en
à peine quelques mois la ministre de la
famille s'est forgé une réputation de
femme de caractère
certains parlent même d'intransigeance
bien sûr pas être traitée manipulatrice
et bien c'est vrai c'est bien revendique
totalement anti pas manipulatrice ça
m'intéresse pas mais vous assumez
l'intransigeance je pense que j'ai des
convictions oui mais je pense que
quelquefois il faut alors le faire avec
plus ou moins de souplesse j'espère
qu'avec le temps j'ai acquis cette
souplesse nécessaire mais je pense aussi
qu'il faut pas être dans le conformisme
et aurélie c'est peut-être un
apprentissage justement de et de
françois mitterrand et de ségolène royal
que de ne pas être du réformisme ans on
va y venir mais c'est vrai qu'on aurait
aurélie filippetti et votre collègue du
gouvernement dites vous alors elle est
plus radicale qu'elle n'en a l'air est
ce que c'est vrai j'ai des convictions
je les assume totalement et puis je
pense que je fais ce cette fonction
quelques ce fut celle de mer ou des
ministres avec les engagements une
grande clarté une grande transparence et
après c'est le verdict des urnes je me
plie totalement vous êtes tenace et si
par exemple le gouvernement l'exacte
n'en soit intransigeante l'accord
d'octobre
si par exemple françois hollande ont
renoncé à cette loi sur la famille à
laquelle vous vous tenez notamment
dispositions sur la paix m
est ce que vous seriez prête à quitter
le gouvernement s'ils font diffusion ne
sont pas respectées siens voilà vous
venez de rajouter quelque chose de très
important qui serait en contradiction
avec mes convictions je tiens à vous
dire que vraiment j'ai eu l'occasion
encore récente de pouvoir discuter avec
justement françois hollande de cette
fois famille je n'ai pas senti de
contradiction avec mes convictions
donc je suis confiante sur la capacité à
faire évoluer tout simplement le droit
de la famille c'est ça dont il s'agit
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure vos
mentors si on peut le dire en politique
françois mitterrand mais aussi laurent
fabius que vous avez suivi pendant
longtemps et puis ségolène royal vous
avez été très fidèle aux trois dans cet
ordre le seul avec qui vous avez rompu
c'est laurent fabius au moment
énorme sur l'europe exactement parce que
lui n'était plus fidèle à ce moment là
vos convictions et à ses côtés tout
comme moi j'avais été son parcours je ne
partageais pas ce choix sûr je suis
profondément européenne est là pour le
coup ça entre en contradiction avec ce
que je pense est nécessaire pour
l'europe aujourd'hui pour se trouver
dans mon gouvernement que lui mais oui
ben c'est bien vous avez gardé quand
même de bons contacts avec l'ugtg way
salut royal et vous vous êtes tous
finalement on pourrait dire des produits
de la mitterrandie quel lien commun
saleh cents d'entre vous trois je pense
que tous ceux qui ont eu l'occasion de
travailler quelle que soit leur niveau
de responsabilité avec françois
mitterrand
on était formé à l'exercice de la
politique d'une façon générale à une
réflexion sur ce que signifie le pouvoir
et le plus le pouvoir aux plus hautes
fonctions à roussines ce que je disais
être capable de ne pas être forcément
dans le conformisme dans ce que
j'appelle moi l'air du temps et qu'elle
et voilà ça ne sait pas toujours si
simple et puis françois mitterrand
disait que il il fallait savoir dire non
que c'était beaucoup plus facile
enfin beaucoup plus que justement elle
était beaucoup plus confortable je vais
y arriver pendant de dire oui que de
savoir dire non mais que lui avait cette
exigence de savoir dire non et je pense
qu'ils la trouvaient tout à fait raison
aujourd'hui vous travaillé aux côtés de
christiane taubira
une autre forte personnalité est-ce que
c'est difficile de s'imposer d'exister à
ses côtés mais je crois que j'ai trouvé
ma place je pense que nous avons été
complémentaires mais écoutez chacun a sa
personnalité moi je suis moins extérieur
que peut l'être voilà la personnalité de
christiane taubira peut-être vous disiez
qu'on me connaît peut-être moins bien
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
souvent été dans la discrétion je n'ai
pas éprouvé la nécessité pour faire de
la politique d'être dans
l'extériorisation de ma propre personne
il faut aimer ça aussi vous l'avez vécu
aux côtés de ségolène royal il faut
aimer ce côté très lumière oui mais
j'étais derrière françois mitterrand
j'étais derrière ségolène royal
maintenant je m'assume je dirais comme
une grande fille satan mais c'était
aussi un apprentissage moi j'ai beaucoup
appris aux côtés de l'une et de l'autre
et au fond voilà ça me permet aussi de
de savoir prendre de la distance y
compris par des personnalités qui
peuvent être très forte et qui voit là
ne m'empêche pas d'exister d'être ce que
je suis et je revendique une certaine
rigueur un sérieux un certain engagement
des convictions
ouais et pourtant parfois aussi vous
êtes comme la semaine dernière au sénat
mise en minorité
devant la haute assemblée par la droite
et par la gauche confondues savais que
je n'ai pas peur de sortir du
conformisme et ça a quand même été sans
doute un de vos premiers grands moments
de solitude en politique mais il en
existe il en existe je pense qu'il faut
savoir aussi c'est peut-être cela aussi
que à tant de nos concitoyens savoir
poser des jalons
peut-être que le temps le temps n'était
peut-être pas venu pour expliciter ce
que j'ai explicite et je pense que
j'étais venu d'ailleurs de leurs enfants
alors c'est j'entends bien j'ai entendu
les oppositions il faut savoir aussi
entendre abandonné les choses le temps
n'est pas mûre bon le temps n'est pas
mûr je prends acte que le temps n'est
pas mûre est ce que pour cela il faut
renoncer à ses convictions
non je pense que nous aurons l'occasion
de revenir sur l'ensemble de ces mots ou
deux ou trois d'autres exemples de votre
anti conformisme vous avez des exemples
rapidement moi je pense que ça a été dit
par gaëtan gorce et c'était juste
choisir ségolène royal au moment des
primaires ça n'était pas un choix
courageux qu'elle vous seriez
anticonformiste je ne sais pas non je
pense que c'est plutôt dans la dans la
démarche c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné je ne suis pas là pour plaire
voilà je on m'a souvent dit on m'a
souvent dit on m'a souvent dit mais vous
vous n'allez pas satisfaire telle ou
telle partie de votre électorat
bah oui bah oui je prends aussi ce
risque et je me suis rendu compte que
comme maire d'arrondissement
j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir des habitants
qui vous sont toujours reconnaissante
d'être dans la clarté et la transparence
merci d'avoir été avec no mercy péri la
semaine prochaine notre invité sera
marine le pen
bonsoir à tous
la à peu près de karystos devant
frigidaire c'est à dire que moi ça fait
dix ans que je travaille à la mairie
dans son opposition
la phrase la plus longue qui m'est
adressée c'est de me dire bonjour la
même chose on commence à développer mais
de qui parle t elle tout simplement de
celui qui dans la vie politique
française et suit traditionnellement le
plus de critiques à savoir le premier
ministre
alors jean marc ayrault est il victime
de son style ou de sa fonction comme
avant lui françois fillon
que penser de ces recadrage et de
l'autorité qui cherchent à imposer et
comment se sortir de ses premiers mois à
la tête du gouvernement
cette semaine nous déshabillons en tout
bien tout honneur le locataire de
matignon
déshabillons dès demain à 18h15 sur
public sénat
comment se déplacer mieux et à moindre
coût
quelle alternative à la voiture
individuelle itinéraire 10 nous emmène
en alsace vélo transports en commun
expérimentation piétonne au coeur de
l'europe strasbourg donnent l'exemple
vous préférez venir à l'école à pied ou
en voiture
itinéraire bis dimanche à 10h45 sur
public sénat
regardez cette fusée qui décolle c'est
une fusée v2 en fait le premier missile
balistique de l'histoire des bombes
volantes mise au point par les
ingénieurs d'hitler pendant la dernière
guerre mondiale plus de 1300 d'entre
elles se sont abattues sur londres et
plus encore sur le port d'anvers et même
quelques-unes sur paris
bonjour à tous nous sommes à eperlecques
à deux pattes saint-omer dans le
pas-de-calais nous irons également à
wizernes non loin d'ici et bien ce sont
sur ces deux sites des sites historiques
que l'on trouve aujourd'hui encore les
derniers vestiges les derniers
témoignages des armes secrètes du
troisième reich
des témoignages faits de pierres de
ferraille et de béton tombent des
banques ça boume sur problème
dépend donc ça tombe un moment du monde
savait
bonjour hubert de magie bonjour vous
êtes le propriétaire de ce site
d'éperlecques et quand on arrive ici on
est extrêmement surpris par le
gigantisme du site est vrai qu'il s'agit
là d'un des blockhaus les plus
importants d'europe
oui si l'on le compas idée base sous
marine
je dirais non mais en volume et rien
extérieur effectivement c'est le plus
grand groupe
alors ce blockhaus était très rapidement
construit finalement qu'il a construit
ce blockhaus à ce blockhaus été
construite en un temps record puisque 1
il a été construit en neuf mois avec
deux vagues de construction alors ces
allemands qui l'ont construit c'est
l'équipe de flou ce qui s'est occupé de
la construction du blockhaus
d'éperlecques comme la majorité des
blockhaus qui n'ont été construit sur le
littoral n'est en général c'est hitler
qui a décidé et voulu ce blockhaus un
blockhaus finalement extrêmement
polyvalent le logo du galec et une usine
qui regroupe une première usine de
réception de stockage 208 fusé après ces
fusées vont passer d'une deuxième chaîne
qui est une chaîne de préparation pâtir
et après loin de pâtir commandé par une
tour de contrôle qui sera à l'extérieur
des locaux c'est à dire que les fusées
elle même ces fameux v2 n'était pas
construit ici il s'était construit
ailleurs en allemagne
les deux étaient construits à doha du
lean souterraine puis été acheminés
jusqu'à éperlecques via éventuellement
des silos de stockage et dc était prévu
de lancer 36 fusée par jour avec deux
papetières
alors je voudrais qu'on vient d'un petit
peu sur la situation géographique du
site nous sommes en pleine forêt la
manche n'est pas très loin
londres non plus londres qui est
l'objectif d'adolphe hitler et les
allemands pouvaient pas trouver mieux
dans un triangle entre dunkerque
boulogne et saint-omer
et qu'elle est saoulé nous sommes à
l'intérieur des terres 25 km de la côte
hors dé portée de canon de marine seule
attaque aérienne peut être possible mais
ce massif forestier s'élève à 87 mètres
d'altitude
donc les attaques resteront relativement
haute plus est au moins vous êtes précis
alors ces attaques parlons-en
précisément les britanniques bien sûr où
un oeil sur ce blockhaus d'éperlecques
et leurs supers forteresse leurs
bombardiers aussi sept ans 43 convié des
bombardements mais sinon oui
l'idée c'est de stopper les travaux de
telle manière légalement les plus la
force et la puissance de redémarrer un
tel chantier avant la fin de la guerre
il ya eu des bombardements et des bombes
tomboy monde tomboy qui sont des grosses
ventes de 6 tonnes sont largués à un peu
plus de 5000 pieds et qui arrivent au
sol avec un poids d'une vitesse un peu
près que
l'acte 2 2 fois la vitesse du son donc
s'enfonce en profondeur dans le sol des
cocktails et explosent elles ont un
phénomène de tremblement de terre et
d'istok un peu tout et bien merci
beaucoup d'aires de mégille au revoir et
merci
après la destruction du blockhaus la
décision d'hitler et de son état-major
fut extrêmement rapide il est vrai qu'il
y avait urgence compte tenu de l'avancée
des forces alliées décision est donc
prise de transférer les activités de ce
site celui d'éperlecques sera notre site
lui aussi destiné à lancer des fusées v2
un site situé sur la commune de wizernes
non loi dit